so we're in a subdivision near  near durango and desert inn you can see  this yellow tape it's blocking off a  part of golden cypress ave  and so now the house that this took  place at is actually around the corner  on maple valley we don't have any  details just yet of course you can see  there is heavy police presence and a  part of the road is blocked off again  this is the time when kids are getting  up for school catching the bus so  this is  somewhat of a slight inconvenience for  those who are in this neighborhood but  police are on the scene and responding  to that homicide situation that again is  around the corner on maple valley so  there should be a media briefing soon we  should be learning more about this  situation within the next half hour or  so so once we know those details we will  keep you updated online and here on air  back to you in the studio